[Music]
that's my
girl yeah who's been working so so hard
you got that head on over got yourself
this flowless body aching out from head
to toe ain't a ain't a my ladies around
the world Ain Ain better get you been
down before you been
H you got
up you be good to go good to
go got get get
mad it got dir let me feel let me your
high that's my girl that's my
girl that's my my
girl that's my
girl what you waiting for that's my
girl a Ain you you know you ain't
nothing ain't better get back you been
down before
you been
H you got
up you be good to go good to
go
[Music]
got let
me me put your high that's my girl
that's my
girl that's my
girl that's my girl what you wa what you
wa what you waiting for that's my girl
you been down before you
been you got
up you'll be good
to said you got to get up and get it get
inever forg it on me brush it up for you
let me put your F
High let my
go
that's
my that's my what you what you what you
waiting for that's
my that's
my that's my that's my that's my that's
Ain Ain Ain put your heart soul Ain
a put your heart in your in it that's
my that's my
girl that's my
girl that's my girl that's my
girl my
girl